Okay. So as we move from
radical to ionic reactions,
Homo Lumo reactions, uh, we have
to take into account salvation.
So do they will do that.
And h bonding,
talk about Ayana fours
and Bruns debt acidity.
We might begin nuclear
fillic substitution first.
The answer to that puzzle that, that
we had for homework last time. Uh,
the question is how you get to
the Aldehyde from the alcohol, uh,
by free radical chain
substitution reaction.
And you remember that you had a
substitute the hydrogen with the chlorine,
you know how to do that. And then it was,
and then if you have a base around it,
it doesn't have to be a strong base.
You can pull off the Proton and lose the
chlorine chloride simultaneously in an
elimination reaction to
generate the carbon eel.
And I think a lot of people got that and
notice that those things happen at the
same time that the departure
of the chloride opens up
a Lumo that helps take the
electrons from the Oah bond.
So the Oah bond is weakened by
the fact of the chloride leaving.
So all those things are happening at once.
And we'll talk more when we get to
elimination reactions about the timing of
that process. Okay. Uh,
so the base that removes the
Proton could be a very weak base.
It could be just the
unshared pair of an alcohol,
or even have a by sulfite
by sulfite an ion.
Now that might not be the way it
actually happens in 30% sulfuric acid.
So I asked you to think
of another mechanism,
one involving Homo lumos substitution.
So the question is,
what's the homo and what's the Lumo?
So the homos and unshared bear on the
alcohol and the Lumo is the sigma star of
the nitrogen chlorine bond,
which is especially a low because of the
positive charge on the nitrogen. Okay.
So we can do a substitution
reaction and this will then,
uh, uh, uh, put the chlorine on to, um,
to the alcohol. The positive
charge you're going to get rid of,
which you can just do by the amine
that was generated in the same process.
It can take off the proton.
Okay.
Which you notice as a substitution
reaction that hydrogen, uh,
substituting nitrogen in place
of oxygen on the hydrogen. Okay.
So then we have,
uh,
the same compound as above except the
hydrogen and the chlorine or exchanged in
their position. So you can do the
same thing again, bring in a base,
pull off the Proton and lose the chloride.
Now you don't usually think of basis
taking protons off from normal carbon
atoms, but this isn't a normal carbon
atom because the chlorides leaving.
So there's something that can
take the electrons as you,
as the base pulls the Proton off.
So the same kind of elimination just
backwards gives the same product.
So that was the mechanisms that I
was hoping you might be able to see.
So in the lecture we were talking about
what holds molecules together other than
bonding,
right about non bonded interactions.
And those are visible in the
physical properties of the ALC.
Yohe lights in the boiling point
and now Keynes do anything,
any liquid for that matter.
So we looked last time and saw that the
dipole dipole interaction could hold
[inaudible] together.
Right?
But that can't be all it is because that
gets large and then get small again.
And the boiling points
keep going up all the time.
So there must be something else.
And that something else is polarizability
the fact that if you have a lot of
electrons and they're far out and high
and orbitals so that they're easily
sloshed around, right?
That is, it's polarizable.
Then you can have interactions between
the dipole and something that gets
polarized by the dipole or indeed
between two instantaneous dipoles.
Uh, and we see that,
uh, that iodide here is,
is much more polarizable than fluoride.
So that's the other mechanism that's
holding the molecules together under, uh,
that is between molecules,
the bonding between molecules
than non bonded interactions.
And then we said last time,
let's look at hydrocarbons and see what
they tell us at butane and isobutane,
neo pentane and pente normal Ben Dane.
So here are the boiling points
for end butane and isobutane.
And you see that as you
make it a more branched,
it's an isomer at the same Adams,
right? But as you make it more branched,
the, uh, the, uh, boiling
point goes down, right?
It's easier to pull the molecules
apart to make them in the gas phase.
The same thing is true of pentane normal
pentane go down eight degrees to get
the ISO Pentane and Neo Pentane goes down,
uh,
by another 18 degrees,
right?
So polarizability does its job well
only when things are close together,
right? Remember that's one over r to the
end dependence. So it falls off rapidly.
The energy you can get from this. So if
you have the same Adams, for example,
here in, in, uh, in normal pentane.
So we got five in a row,
we have to get the atoms close together
to allow their polarizability to hold
the molecules together.
So with these,
you can put them side by
side and that's great.
And all the atoms in one molecule or
near all the atoms in another molecule.
But if it's a branched
compound like neo pentane here,
where the four of methyl
groups are on the same Adam,
then you can't get them nearly as close
to one another. For purposes of, of, uh,
of having the polarizability do the trick
and we have a picture here so that you
can see it better on the next slide.
Uh,
so it's atoms that are near the surface
of the molecule that count atoms that
are deep down inside a molecule,
don't get close enough to their
neighbors to profit from this very much.
So there's an above and Pentane
and below neo pentane right?
And here you can see how much closer you
can get the molecules and if you'd like
to see whether you can get them closer
than I suggested and holding here,
I'll pass these around and you can
hold them and have a good time.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now you can see something a little bit
like that in the heat of formation,
the stability of the molecules.
Notice that the heat of formation of
Neo Pentane is larger, more negative,
more downhill to form neo
Dane than to form an Pentane.
And that's it.
Part of that must be the same reason that
the polarizability can operate within
a molecule as well as between molecules.
And when you get all the atoms,
not to be spread out,
but to be more in a ball,
then the Addams within the
molecule or near one another.
So what you lose in terms of
polarizability from molecule,
from one molecule at a,
at being adjacent to another one,
you gain in interactions
within the molecule.
So that's not the only reason for this,
but that's one reason that
branching is more stable,
makes molecules more stable.
So it's like salvation except that
happens within the molecule rather than
between molecules.
And you can see the thing,
the same principle in a more pronounced
way when there's an actual charge to do
the polarizing, right? So if
we look here at the gas phase,
ionic dissociation,
so how much energy does it take to break
a chloride away from our to make our
plus. So we look at the stability,
the end of the r plus cad ion,
and you can see that it's ever
so much easier. 53 kilocalories.
It easier to make tea butyl
than it is to make methyl.
Now there are a number of factors that
are involved there and we're going to
discuss others as well.
But one of the factors is certainly
that the positive charge, stable gain,
stability by polarizing the material
that's around it and the more material you
have around it,
the closer to the positive charge,
the more stability you're going to get.
So that's one of the factors that's
involved here. It's not the only factor,
but this interim molecular salvation,
I mean that's sort of
a stupid thing to say,
but that must be one of the factors
that helps explain these trends.
Yeah.
Now here we look at the boiling points
of the normal alkanes with different
chain lengths and halogen on the end
or in the first case,
hydrogen.
So here and alkanes has hydrogen on the
end of the chain. Then Khloe fluoride,
chloride, bromide iodide. This
is a from from the textbook,
the Jones Textbook.
And here we see them a colored a so you
can see what Adam's involved, right?
So one would infer from this that
for some reason, I mean just the,
the impression it makes on me as a viewer
is that something suggests that the
iodides are low boiling.
Do you see what I'm saying?
That curve falls below the others.
But what does,
what does molecular weight have
to do with boiling point notice?
What's being plotted here is molecular
weight against boiling point.
But what relevance does molecular
weight have to boiling point? Yeah.
There's sort of an intuitive
idea that if something's heavy,
it's hard to get up in the gas
phase. Right? But that's, that's,
that has nothing to do with boiling
point, right? That's a pure nonsense.
The question is, is there a better way
to plot this to see what's going on?
And I think there is,
which is instead of plotted against the
molecular weight plot against the length
of the chain, right? How big is
the molecule? So if we do that too.
So we plot in here in Hch to
take an end times and then x,
and now we'll change x from hydrogen to
fluorine, chlorine, bromine, to then,
okay, now fluorine is almost
the same as hydrogen, right?
When it's a really short chain,
the fluoride is a little bit like,
that's methyl fluoride,
that's higher boiling and hydrogen,
we already explained that the dipoles
that are in the ch three f can interact
with one another in a favorable way,
okay. But once you get a real long chain,
that's not a very big
fraction of the total.
And it comes to look pretty
much like the alkanes.
But now look what happens
if you go instead of, uh,
so the dipole moment is
bigger for fluoride than it
is for the hydrogen, right?
But the polarize abilities
or about the same, right?
But if it chloride is more polarizable,
it has more electrons further out.
Right?
So although it has essentially the
same dipole moment is the fluoride,
it's polarizability,
it's a greater polarizability as
clearly holding things together.
And the same thing is true
when you go on to bromide,
which is still more
polarizable and to iodide,
which is the most polarizable at all.
So it has sort of backhand way,
it's related to molecular weight because
the more electrons you have in the Adam,
the further out they are,
the more they slosh around,
the more polarizable they are.
But the electrons have
nothing to do with the weight.
It's the nucleus that has
to do with the weight,
but more electrons mean more neutrons
and more protons in the nucleus.
So it's sort of parallel,
but I think it's more informative
to look at it this way,
to see what it is that's really
holding the molecules together. Okay.
Now you've heard the, the
ancient say like dissolves, like,
and you've seen things like soup
that has clubs of the, of the fat,
uh, floating around into
obviously not mixing with water.
Uh, and you've heard tell of
solid though. PHOBIC forces,
probably hydrophobic forces.
So the, so there seems to be,
the name implies it antagonism
between water and, and uh,
al Qaeda in the grease, right?
That tends to push them apart.
So you've got islands of Greece
and in a matrix of water,
uh,
now here's droplets of mercury on a,
on a cover slip on glass.
And you can see that the mercury beads up,
it doesn't spread out.
And what the glass,
so it seems that mercury
doesn't wet glass, right?
So there seems to be a phobic
force between glass and
mercury that tends to push
them apart to keep them
separate from one another.
And here we see droplets of mercury in a,
in a polyethylene,
a container.
And you can see that it beads up that
mercury doesn't wet hydrocarbon either.
So it looks like they are
antagonistic to one another. Right?
And the same thing is true of water.
Water doesn't wet a waxed car or,
or a hydrocarbon,
right? That's, that's, that's hydrophobic
forces. That's like the, the grease.
They stay apart right now if
that's so can you tell me,
should mercury repel uh,
water?
Okay.
So if we touch a drop of
water to a drop of mercury,
should they stay apart as beads or
should they spread on each other?
How many of you think they should
be antagonistic and fan form beads?
Okay.
Okay. How many think they should
spread on one another? It's a, well,
there's a slight slight excess there,
but pretty close to a tie.
And I think there are a number
of individuals not voting,
so we can do the experiment,
right?
See how the water comes over
and grabs onto the Burke Uri.
So clearly there's an affinity
between mercury and water, right?
But in fact,
there's also affinity between mercury
and glass and there's affinity between Al
Alkane and, and, and water, right? This,
it's a misleading term to say phobic, that
these things are avoiding one another,
right? Clearly, mercury
attracts water, right?
But al and water or mercury in
glass don't repel one another.
There's attraction between
them as you expect. There's,
there's going to be the Po,
if nothing else,
they'll be the mutual polarization of
one atom by another across this boundary
that will tend to hold things together,
right?
But Mercury is particularly good.
It has so many electrons out
there that could be polarizable.
Mercury holds to mercury very,
very tightly and water,
uh, likes to be near water
for hydrogen bonding,
which is what we're going to cost.
But water likes to be near Mercury,
but not as much as mercury
likes to be near Mercury. Okay?
So water with mercury is a
good interaction from the
point of view of the water.
The water's the dipole.
The mercury has polarizable.
There's good attraction there,
right?
But Mercury doesn't want
to change its shape.
It wants to have as many mercury
Adams as close together as possible.
It's like the owl cane,
right? The Neo Pentane, they,
Adam's want to be close to one
another to be low in energy.
So you don't want to distort mercury
because it has so much attraction between
the atoms,
but water,
it attracts mercury better
than it attracts itself.
So it spreads out on the mercury.
So these, these, these salvo,
phobic forces are not really questioned.
The things being antagonistic
to one another. There's a,
that's a question of something
really wanting to be close to itself.
For some particular reason. Mercury
with mercury is very good, uh,
attraction,
but water with water to
water will attract a Greece.
Right?
But it attracts itself much better.
So it wants to stay connected to itself.
Okay. And this brings up the question of
what is it that holds water to itself.
And of course we heard last
time about hydrogen bonding.
So let's think about why hydrogen bonding.
So water has a dipole,
so you can imagine that two of
them would line up this way,
positive to negative the dipoles.
But actually this is the calculated dimer
structure for water calculated in 2000
water gets worked on so much
and it's been worked on forever.
Anybody that has a theoretical
technique tries to do it with water.
And the main thing is that
although they hold together,
they don't hold together very strongly.
The dimerization energy is only about
three kilocalories per mole, right?
And it, there's a lot of flexibility
in it because it's rather weak.
But the very lowest energy according to
this particular calculation is this one.
Now, what is it that's holding
there? There's a hydrogen
between the two oxygens.
The hydrogen of one of the molecules
is between the two oxygens.
But let's look at the bond distances.
There's 95 pico meters.
That's 0.95 angst drums,
right?
And same over here on the left,
but the bridging one is nine six,
three, 9.96. Well, it's longer,
but it's not much longer, right? So the,
it's lengthened by only 0.5%.
Okay?
So there's not much electron
pair from one oxygen, uh,
donating into sigma star of the other one.
That's what you would expect
for a bond, right? It has,
it has lengthened the
bond to the hydrogen. Uh,
now how would you expect
the, the, the, uh,
waters to line up according to their,
we looked at the charge last time,
the dipole,
but it's not waters,
just the positive charge here in a
negative charge here at a certain distance
from one another. The electrons are
spread all out with different densities.
So you can analyze it as multiples,
not only a dipole moment,
but also a quadrupole moment,
which is plus, plus, minus, minus,
and an octopus and a hex indexical moment.
This is hard to do in your head,
but one thing you can do with, with a
spartan or other graphic pro pro, uh,
programs is draw this
electrostatic surface potential
that we've talked about to
see where on the surface
of Proton would be happy.
That's where it's red or unhappy,
where it's blue and the
energies are minus 47,
very favorable in the
blue area to plus 60.
Very unfavorable in the red area
for a proton at the surface. Okay?
Now let's look at the, uh, at the one
on the right there and let's rotate it.
So we site right along the h
o bond, right? And if we look,
we see that it's blue. They're a good
place to, a bad place to put a proton,
a good place to put something negative,
right?
And this is the color scale here it goes.
Instead of minus 47 to 60,
while this is minus 45 to 60,
right?
But we can home in audit to get the colors
to show what we want by going plus 55
to plus 60 or,
and now,
now you see that there's a very small
region there, which is the best, right?
The are probably the best place
to put something negative,
the worst place to put something
positive, right? And if we look at it,
we see that that you get as you move the
proton up and down their back and forth,
uh, you changed by half a
kilo calorie promotional.
If you go up and down
by half an Armstrong,
which would correspond
then if you went up there,
that's where we're
looking at on the surface.
So that's a plus or minus nine
degrees up and down. Okay,
so that, so that's a fairly tiny target,
although it doesn't cost, you know,
half of kilocalories and the enormous,
you could go further and not lose
too much. But look at the oxygen end.
If we rotate that one and look at
the water, and from the oxygen end,
we see there's a very big
streak of red that is 10,
that's a 10 kilocalories,
a total range from,
from, uh, from on the color
scale. And if we go, uh,
here to down to five,
which is the same scale be used over here,
it's waste spread out.
And even if we go further to only one
and a half kilo kilocalories per mole,
you see that, that, that, uh, uh,
that for the entire color scale,
you can see that that red range
goes quite far up and down 0.3,
eight angst terms plus
or minus 25 degrees,
and the energy changes only 0.05.
So it's very big red target
that you can tolerate.
So you have a tall target there and a
small target on the other one, right?
And now when you put them
together this way, you see,
you can bend these down and get these
hydrogens far away from that one and still
have very good contact between [inaudible]
between the places that complimentary
charges are good to sit.
Um, that's a very, uh,
qualitative sort of analysis of this.
But it's a sort of funny minimum
energy structure for water.
But the important thing is that it's
consistent with just how the charges of
isolated waters would interact with one
another. Just charge charge interaction.
There's no special bonding.
Quantum mechanics didn't come into this.
Once you had the water molecules,
you'd bring them together and that's
a reasonable way for them to fit.
And the dissociation energy is not large.
It's 3.3 kilocalories per mole,
but you can get other waters around
in about. So taking a a water out of,
out of, uh, uh,
out of taking a water molecule
into the gas phase out of water is,
is much more of course than
three kilocalories per mole.
So the important thing that
makes high from this perspective,
what makes hydrogen bonding important
is that you have these dipoles,
but they can get very
close to one another.
Because remember the energy falls off
very rapidly with distance because
hydrogen is so small,
it can get very close to the
oxygen and have a dipole.
So it's just dipole dipole interaction.
Like you have in any of these
other things we were looking at,
but they can get really,
really close to one another.
So you get more energy in the case
of hydrogen bonds, then you do, uh,
for other dipoles, right. So
nothing special. It's not,
there's no real bonding to it.
It's just that the molecules can come
together and be low in energy that way.
And typically that hydrogen
bonding is less than 5%.
Often much less than 5% is
strong as a covalent bond.
So a hydrogen bond isn't anything like
the bonds we talked about last semester
or is it
a hydrogen bonding can be subtle
and it's the subject of continuing
investigation. And there's a, uh, uh,
professor Johnson in the physical chemist
in our department is doing a lot of
work on instructor of water
and Professor Jorgenson,
a theoretician has done a lot
of work on water as well. Uh,
so if you have ions involved,
so not neutral waters coming together,
but here the protonated water
coming together with a water.
Then the question is what kind of hydrogen
bonding are you going to get in this
case?
And now the heat involved in those
things coming together instead of 3.3
kilocalories per mole is 10 times greater,
32 kilocalories per mole.
But of course there's an entropy price
to pay when you pull these things
together.
So the actual free energy change and
bringing them together isn't nearly as
favorable because you're localizing things
that we're free to move around before.
So the free energy change at 300 Kelvin
is eight kilocalories per mole, uh,
in the gas phase. Right. But
here's what's interesting.
There's the structure of this,
uh,
h five o two plus.
What do you notice about it as
compared to the water diver?
I gets bonded.
Why do you think so Lauren?
Why do you think it's bonded?
Because like the lines are going both
ways and like it looks like it's sitting
right in the middle of right.
The hydrogen is right in the middle.
It's not like the other one where the
hydrogen was a normal bond distance from
one oxygen and quite far from the
other one. It's right in the middle.
And in fact,
if you do a calculation of how much
energy it takes to move that hydrogen back
and forth,
you see that it's a single minimum,
not a double minimum,
where it could be part of the time on one
part of the time on the other and jump
back and forth. It's a single
minimum. The h plus is equally shared.
So this case is real bonding, right?
A single minimum in the middle.
Now how about if we do a,
the anti an example h three o two minus
hydroxide being hydrogen bonded by
water. So what's the question
there? What's the answer there?
We know that that the energy involved is
rather similar to what it is for the h
five o two it's 27 kilocalories
per mole in the gas phase.
But uh,
the structure is quite,
is rather different or is it right?
Is the,
is the hydrogen halfway in between?
Okay.
Well what do you notice about
this one compared to the cad I am,
it's a double minimum now.
Not a single minimum.
So it's lower in energy when the
hydrogen is on one end or the other.
At a maximum local maximum in
the middle. Right. However,
hydrogen is very light.
Yeah.
What does that have to do with it?
Go back to the beginning of last semester.
Pardon me tonally.
Right.
If you look at the very lowest energy
level for moving the hydrogen back and
forth, you'll see something interesting.
So this is a double minimum.
The hydrogen is not
symmetrically bound along this,
but it can't have the minimum
energy and the barrier is very low,
only 0.6 kilocalories per mole.
So if you look at the lowest
energy vibrational wave function,
it looks like that.
So even though it's a double minimum,
the hydrogen spends most
of its time in the middle
and the course,
the reason that can do that is that the
reason that can spend most of its time
in the middle is because there is
some bonding that lowers its energy.
Where there, so there is, there
is, there can be hydrogen bonding.
We saw it in in h three o plus plus water.
We see it in hydroxide plus water,
even though it's a double
minimum and potential energy,
it the thing can be in the middle. So
there is real bonding there. And in fact,
in pure water without ions,
if you have high pressure that forces,
the water's closer together. So the
better part of a million atmospheres,
and this can be done in the laboratory,
uh,
the oxygen's get closer
together and closer together.
And what was a double minimum
becomes a single minimum.
And the structure of this form 10 of ice
water is nothing if not versatile right
there more than 10 different structures
of ice that have been observed.
But this particular high pressure one,
as you can see from the structure,
has hydrogens halfway between.
So it's no longer a molecular water.
It's entire crystal.
The whole thing is one molecule with
hydrogen bonds holding it together.
But this is not what we usually are
talking about in terms of hydrogen bonds.
Normal hydrogen bonds are just this
polar interaction which are favorable
because hydrogen so small and
can get close to other things.
Okay. Now we're going
to go on from, from uh,
this digression about water to talk
about crown ethers and what are called
tailored Ayana fours. So
here's, here's a crown.
Ether it, it, you can, uh,
you have to be imaginative
to see that as a crown, but,
but you can sort of imagine putting it
on your head and have all the little
things go up around it.
I suppose that's where the name came from.
So this idea of having an oxygen and
then a bridge of two carbons and another
oxygen bridge, oxygen bridge in a ring.
Those are the crowns. So they have a name.
This is 18 crown six.
So it's a crown alternating oxygen and
two carbons, oxygen and two carbons,
right? And it's six because they're
six oxygens in it. And this is the,
this was one of the earliest ones,
uh, studied, uh, and in fact,
uh,
these,
these crown ethers resulted in the Nobel
prize in chemistry for the people who
discovered and exploited them in,
in 1987.
Ayana for means and I,
and carrier,
the Greek root for us
means to carry things.
So these things are able to carry ions.
Let's see how that works.
So here's 18,
crown,
six viewed from the top and from
the side with potassium chloride,
and you see the potassium is held inside.
I'll pass this around so you can
see it. Here's, here's the, uh,
the ring of, of six oxygens
connected by pairs of ch two groups.
And it turned out that a golf ball
is about the right scale to be the,
to have the radius of a potassium
ion on the scale of these models.
And you see it fits right in the
middle. The, the, if we look at the ox,
the six oxygens, they're not all
in a plain, as you can see there,
there are three of them up
in three of them down. Right?
Does that remind you of anything,
Megan?
Just like Cyclohexane, he goes up,
down and down and down the chair.
Cyclohexane right?
Uh,
and the potassium sits right in the
middle with three above and three below.
And I'll pass that around so you can,
so you can see it.
Yeah.
So potassium is just the right size to
fit in there. Fits right in the middle.
And if we look at the actual
distances that are involved,
you can see these distances
are all about a 2.8 on streams,
which is just about exactly the,
some of the ionic Radii I of potassium
and the covalent radius of oxygen at 2.7
that would be,
those numbers aren't really such great
numbers so that it really fits right?
Okay.
Now what if you use a
bigger eye like caesium.
So cesium is 1.7 Ostrom.
So now 3.1 instead of 2.7 for
the oxygen cesium distance.
Right
now you can see that it's because caesium
is larger. It can't get in the middle.
It sits on top,
close to three of the oxygens,
and further from the bottom three oxygens.
There's the view from the back,
okay?
Now here, here's the skeleton with
the balls for the atoms of that,
and you can see that the closer
oxygens are at Vander walls,
distance 3.1 a extremes,
but the others are closer
to 3.2 or 3.3 ox drums.
Okay?
Now that distance is 4.8
on extremes, right? Well,
what happens if you would make it
even smaller? I'd in the middle.
Okay.
You can try to shrink clearing down,
right?
But if you pull those two closer together
in order to make all five of these
closer to whatever's in the middle,
then that one's going to get squeezed out.
All right?
So here's what happens. If you go to
sodium, right? And now that different,
that distance is 4.0 right. Uh, uh,
roughly at Ostrom's closer in order
to get these close to the, uh,
to the sodium sodium,
the oxygen is 2.4 right?
So that that sixth one got squeezed out,
but it came in from the bottom.
So if we look at the distances,
those are all in the
neighborhood of 2.4 2.51 is 2.6,
so just a little bit bigger than,
than the Vanderwall is distance
and one on the bottom is 2.4.
So it squeezes underneath
and there's just, just happy.
But it leaves space on the top.
And this particular crystal
structure has had a water in it.
So the water is up on top
at 2.32 Ostrom's. Yeah.
And if we get smaller still with lithium,
now the lithium can't shrink
the ring down anymore.
It gets close to just two of them.
A 2.2 oxygens.
Notice that's 2.1 and 2.1 2.07,
but it's further from the
others. Right? So, but,
and it notice it sits right in the
middle of the, of the, of the, uh,
the main plane of these things.
But what happens with interactions
with the far oxygen's,
this one has two waters,
so the water's bind to the lithium
and then the protons of the water,
our hydrogen bonded to those far oxygens.
So lithium increases at
size by incorporating two
waters with it so it can fit
in this thing.
Okay.
Now look at the equilibrium constant for
binding the cat ions to this 18 crown
six that notice that potassium,
uh,
is by far the biggest.
So these are too big.
We looked at cesium sodium and lithium,
or too small,
but potassium is just right.
Okay, so when this is one,
this is 60 times bigger,
okay?
Now the equilibrium constant is of
course the concentration of the complex
divided by the concentrations of the
metal ion and the ligand product,
right? So it has units expressed
this way, it's per molar,
right? And if you look at the actual
value, not just relative to one another,
which was what's plotted first,
but the actual value,
you see that it's over a million,
this equilibrium constant.
Now let's think of what that means.
That one's 23,000 okay?
So what this means is that when,
when the league and down
here equals, uh, let's see,
when,
when the League and Times K is one,
then you have 50% this is one to one,
right?
If you multiply this over here
and that comes out to one,
then you have the same amount of metal
that's uncomplex as you have of metal.
That's complex,
okay?
So what that means is that it's half
complex when you have one micro molar of
the concentration of the league and,
right? So it holds on very, very tightly,
right?
Now bear in mind that there's something
else that could complex with the
potassium ion the uh,
the methanol Sullivan could do.
So this is done in methanol
solvent at room temperature.
Now methanol is 0.7 grams per milliliter.
It's molecular weight is 32, so we can
calculate what its concentration is.
Its concentration is 25 molar,
right?
So the league and is able at at one micro
molar is able to beat out methanol at
25 molar,
right?
So it's 29 million times stronger than
methanol at binding to this by having all
these six arrange. So they grab it
just right, it fits just right. Okay.
The energy involved as 13 kilocalories
per mole of stabilization. Again,
nothing compared to covalent
bonds that we talked about, uh,
and, but it's much more favorable
in the case of, of a potassium.
That is the case of sodium,
which is five kilocalories less.
Okay. But by notice what
this does, when you put this,
this crown around the, the golf
ball, it makes it much bigger,
right? But what holds the salt
assault together is the, the,
the attraction between the cad ion.
And the I in,
which depends very much on distance.
So if you make the ions bigger,
as we mentioned in the last lecture,
they won't interact so strongly so it's
not so stable to be in this in the salt,
in the solid salt farm,
it's easier to dissolve.
So you could dissolve
potassium permanganate in
hydrocarbons if you use crown
ether to put in there to make the
potassium ever so much bigger.
So this has worked out in lab
in a way that's shown here.
So you have some organic solvent and you
have put something in it that you want
to oxidize. So you need an oxidizing
agent. Ah, potassium permanganate,
right? So we have, uh,
we have an organic substance
to be oxidized and we put
in potassium permanganate
and it just sits on the
bottom of the flask.
It doesn't get the where the
where the organic molecules are.
So there's no reaction.
All right, so what that,
but if you,
and if you put water in,
that will dissolve the
potassium permanganate,
but it won't get the potassium per bag
and age where the organic stuff to be
oxidized is.
It'll just be two phases of purple phase
that has the water phase that has the
purveying and aid in it. And then the
organic phase just floating above it.
Yeah.
Okay.
But if you put in the crown ether,
then the Parang Guneet
can dissolve in the,
in the organic solvent and can do the
trick. Right? So by Mike is a cat.
I in large 18 crown six destabilizes
a solid or aqueous Promega and eight
allowing the salt to
dissolve and hydrocarbons.
And people call this purple benzene.
I actually have never done this.
I've never seen Purple Benzene,
but Professors Ziegler has done it.
And he tells me that the Purple Benzene
prepare this way isn't purple at it's
yellow. So, so,
so that's just his one experiment.
So I don't know that it's never purple,
but that's what he told me.
So maybe it maybe purple benzene look
sort of yellow according to Professor
Ziegler.
That would just be because Promega Nate
in an organic solvent has a different
spectrum for prepaying an aid and water
solvent, which wouldn't be surprising. Uh,
but this process is,
but it works.
People are able to do oxidations this
way and it's called phase transfer.
Katala says, cause the idea is to get a
reagent from one phase into the other.
You use the,
the uh,
the crown ether as a catalyst
that doesn't get consumed, right?
It just helps the stuff get there and
do its reaction in the other phase.
So it's Catallo assists and you don't
have to use crown ethers for this,
although they are used for it.
You can get a similar effect by having
other really big cat ions that make it
possible for an anti and to go into the,
to the organic phase.
So Tetra Al ammonium or Tetra
Al Kill Phospho Niamh salts.
And the advantage of these things is that
there are solvents that will dissolve
both organic things and potassium
permanganate or other salt reagents,
but those salts like dimethyl sulfoxide
that we'll do that are dangerous and
they're expensive.
So this is an example of green
chemistry to do chemistry in a more
environmentally favorable
way by using these ethers or,
or simple assaults as a way of,
of getting the reagents to mix.
Okay. Now a further development
on this is called crip. Dan's,
which you notice is like a crown ether,
except that it has a nitrogen in it,
which is try Vaillant rather
than oxygen being divalent.
So you can get another bridge across so
you can get these crypts into which to
hide things.
So here's an example of a crypto hand
and a genre lane who did this work with?
John Pierre Salvage, uh, got,
got the Nobel prize for this,
shared the Nobel prize
for these crown ethers.
So now you can put different numbers of
these. Oh ch two ch two groups in here.
So you could make different
sizes for these rings. Uh,
so here's an example of,
of where l is one.
So you have one bridge that has two
oxygens and to bridge that have one,
two bridges that have one oxygen.
And I've made a model of that here.
So you see there two bridges,
two oxygens here on the top,
but there's one on this way and one here.
And two nitrogens also point
in with their loan pairs.
So that makes it pretty hard.
It's pretty small cavity inside.
I'll pass that one around to you
and you won't be surprised to hear them.
That when you look at the equilibrium
constant in methanol for putting various
salts in there, that lithium is
the one that binds most strongly,
the smallest of the ions. It has an
ionic radius of a little less than,
uh, than, uh, than three
quarters of an angst from.
So it fits. Uh, but sodium doesn't
fit as well. Potassium's bad.
And these are whited out because in fact,
they come down off, they were measured,
but they come way down off the
bottom of this graph. Okay?
Now if you put a make one or the
other bridges have two oxygens in it.
So you increase the size
of the hole a little bit.
Now it binds sodium the best.
And if you put the other bridge
bigger at pines potassium the best,
and if you put two carbons and one of
the bridges, it binds rubidium the vest.
And if you put two carbons in all the
bridges that bind cesium last best,
and I put caesium one 37 here because
that's a byproduct of a isotope in
Richmond.
And nuclear industry,
and it's a common pollutant
that they want to get rid of.
So what they're trying to
do now is to design a crip,
Dan's that will readily bind to cesium.
So you can take the earth
or whatever has been,
or are these a million gallon barrels
that have this waste stuff in him.
Put something in a little specifically
get the cesium, which is the bat,
the worst actor among these,
uh,
among these a radioactive
byproducts that'll take them,
put it in another phase,
and then make it reversible so that you
can take the crypt and off and use it
again. Right? So there's a lot of work
being done on that kind of thing now,
but they're also, it's also can
be used in biology. For example,
there's a bacterial
antibiotic called known actin,
which you see is a ring that
has a lot of oxygens in it.
Now that ring is quite a big one,
but you can curl it around
like this as I show here,
right? Ben? Those ends up right.
And then the chain looks like
the seams on a tennis ball.
But you have all these oxygen's that
can then be directed toward the middle.
So here's a picture of that, uh,
of that wrapped around a cat eye.
And now it's not easy to, to uh, see, uh,
the three dimensions here, but if you
will let it rotate, you can see how,
what the,
uh,
what the shape is of this thing that's
wrapped completely around the potassium
ion with, with, uh,
eight oxygen's coordinated
as the potassium, right?
And they're there,
you can see the seams on a tennis ball,
which traced this chain,
right?
And the equilibrium constant in
methanol for holding onto sodium is 512.
But for potassium, the one that's
shown there, it's, it's 31,000.
So it's very selective, right?
And it's even tighter with,
with ammonia in the middle.
And so how do these things
work in biology? I mean,
I should know. I don't, I don't
know, but, but, uh, but the,
the general idea is that they could
make ions dissolve in organic things,
right? So, you know,
the potential in your cells has to do
with pumping sodium and potassium ions
back and forth.
And creating a gradient.
And if you suddenly put something
in there, it'll say potassium, oh,
can go wherever you want.
Right? That destroys this.
And it's bad for living things.
So anyhow, that th th the,
the biology has a number of things that
can do this kind of trick with ions as
well.
Uh,
now the next topic is the importance
of solvent for ionic reactions.
And I'm gonna start this since
we started a little bit late,
but we'll complete it next time.
So we're interested in the reaction water,
a water molecule in Wa
surrounded by water and water,
solvent dissociated to
give h plus and o h minus,
right?
And we want to know what energy is going
to be involved in that and what will
the equilibrium constant B,
and I think you people know
the equilibrium constant
from your AP chemistry,
but we're going to look at it a different
way as to how, what, what's involved,
what role the solvent plays in this.
So the way we're going to do it
is to look at it without solve it,
by going into the gas phase.
So if we pump in 6.3
kilocalories per mole,
we can make the water,
the water that's in water,
become water in the gas phase.
Okay.
And now we know we can look
up in a Ellison's table,
the bond association energy for Water
and find that it's going to take a 120
kilocalories per mole to get
it apart to h Adam and Ooh,
radical,
right?
And then if we transfer an electron from
one to the other, that's then going to,
going to get us the species
we're interested in.
But in the gas phase,
that's a 392 kilocalories per mole
in toto to do those two things,
those three things. Okay. And
remember the Coolum energy is,
this is the,
the gorilla in this particular scheme,
it's that 332 uh,
kilocalories divided by Armstrong.
So that's the big one.
That's that electron transfer
and getting the ions apart.
So the equilibrium constant
and the gas phase is,
is a 10 to the minus 290 not
a very favorable process.
Okay.
But we know that it can happen in water.
So the Solvan has a lot to do with it,
and we'll talk about that next time.